foreign
the day's deals have been closed at one
of Africa's largest produce markets in
dawana
workers load grains and cereals destined
for domestic markets and to far away
places such as Burkina Faso and Beyond
Market officials say the past few years
have been particularly hard
we hardly get 150 trucks leaving this
Market daily with produced to various
destinations previously that number was
between 300 to 400 trucks a day loaded
with variety of produce
one of the factors he says is this
climate change has Unleashed devastating
floods with losses so far estimated in
hundreds of millions of dollars this
year and more heavy rains are forecast
for the weeks ahead
Farmers also struggle with high
fertilizer cost and a shortage of farm
equipment like tractors experts say
Nigeria this year will have to import
food to make up for the shortfall in
production in 2021 the country's food
import Bill jumped 42 to 5 billion
dollars
and there are further problems facing
Nigeria's food production clearly the
insecurity going on in the country at
the moment is inhibiting or limiting
Nigeria's dreams to achieve food
security an estimated 500 000 Farmers
have been forced off their lands by
criminal gangs who have taken over
entire communities and farms in the
North
with rains becoming unpredictable
experts say the country needs irrigation
schemes
though only 20 of the world arable land
is is under cultivation but that 20
provides forty percent of the world food
requirement so importantly what this is
saying is that if this food if this 20
can be increased to 40 percent to 50
percent then there will be 100 percent
Supply operation through agriculture
officials are planning to do just that
we launch a new program a national
irrigation and drainage program of a
50-year program that will take us to the
year 2030 and within that period our
Target is to at least between the
federal government States local
governments and even commercial farmers
who want to be able to see we can reach
about 50 percent of the total potential
of the country
that requires a lot of money and
commitment until then the country may
have to find ways to meet local food
demands through costly Imports how many
degrees Al Jazeera Northwest Nigeria